what up world it's me Widow Vaughn du
I'm Dahlia thin hey y'all it's me miss
Jada essence ah
I'm Britta hi I'm Nicki doll I am Aidan
Zane hi I'm Jujubee
I'm Rock'em Sock'em I'm Gigi good hi I'm
Heidi in closet Alam it's Jackie Cox hi
everyone I'm Jan I'm crystal method and
we're at BuzzFeed playing whoo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Oh
it's mostly like the reflection part of
it so as long as it's front-facing and I
can see myself them wholeheartedly Jam
one time anybody's her definitely snatch
a few choices
[Music]
I take a long time hello AI still it
like garbage that's the sad part
you are the quickest quick you're the
fast is she painted in the next 20
minutes yeah she's like what making this
is 20 minutes yeah you're always late
because it is it dog is in this growth I
would say myself
oh we were at we were at dinner the
other day you popped upstairs by 30
seconds if you made it in 30 minutes
there was a check on the line hours and
you look beautiful
do you take well it depends if I'm late
I can make it in 40 minutes if I'm not
you just put your finger in your nose I
have a very big canvas to fill it's a
very big face this Julia faces up in my
face the fastest is widow Widow whoop
widow will get up at 7:30 and be outside
ready for the car at 7:45 work she's
ready to get her nap in her car agent
with her cigarette ready to go oh
[Music]
there's definitely me rock oh that is
true haha rock would take over
oh no we're clean it up Britta I'll grow
there's so much stuff be as soon as we
started it was just every girl
everywhere everything I hadn't gotten to
primer yeah and she is just powder on
the floor like you know the table start
over again she's a loving person she
just loves reading more Britta was good
but and his girl who is shady in this
look any of us her [ __ ] the essence of
shake
[Music]
oh babe okay
I think you why because you always
pointed to me I wasn't sure
[Music]
oh yeah season 12 works great oh yeah me
too a little bit but Jan I say Jan
because of Ariana
she is followed by Ariana Grande I know
you and Ariana Grande loves her a lot of
people would be scared here a lot of
people will be scared than anima
oh she's not here too but I would be
pointing at crystal if she was here
because crystal goes into full fangirl
mode you guys we Matt Grayson today
[Laughter]
[Music]
she's not here she's already buckle up
you know just be fine okay and doll
you're so gorgeous
I just can't help myself I have to say
something Dahlia Dahlia Dahlia but in
this room love you fightin no no I
haven't been real good
I was atop of your jugular an MBA yes it
would be a Twitter Oh Twitter Instagram
Grindr any girl there's no tomato matter
so we'll start the beef wherever like I
was talking about Julie your mama and
your grandkids and that's it for you
your mama every generations of families
everywhere she's grabbing everybody's
wig the grandkids like for you are
related to them that's why that's what
you should see our Christian mingle
guys Oh
Jackie's just very smart and she's very
knowledgeable and also very
compassionate so I think like if
anybody's having a moment jackie takes
time out of her day to make sure that
others are okay but I've also got
amazing advice from you I feel like I
trust Berta yeah I got like you would
give it to me straight but if I need
like help with my bangs or questions
like that Gigi Gigi fashion buddy help
with some baby hairs Gigi if someone
were to run for president of us it would
be her because she knows everything
about America even though she's Canadian
[Music]
has anyone answer this question
differently
yo illusional baby and they're
delusional and there's another one baby
and another one away she's cheating
Juche a deserves the crown shady oh she
just like that they're not fighting it
this is what we call a rhetorical
question
look nah this has been a lot of fun but
we gotta wrap this up okay so make sure
you tune in to RuPaul's Drag Race Season
12 Fridays only unbe h1
[Music]